[Musique]
vous connaissez le point commun entre
beyoncé madonna louis xiv
jim kelly rudolf noureev sylvie guillem
tous de grands danseurs allez sur
youtube et vous verrez leur style même
louis xiv va vous verrez un remplaçant
qui danse dans des films où l'on voit la
danse du 17e bon mais comment on a fait
pour retrouver cette danse les témoins
les vidéos et bien eu 14 avait des
maîtres à danser qui ont écrit des
partitions de danse et qui ont permis de
transmettre cette danse car elles sont
conservées ainsi que les tables de qui
les expliquent à la bibliothèque
nationale de l'opéra de paris et donc
voici une partition feuillet c'est beau
c'est de la danse du xviie j'ai appris
la danse
j'ai commencé pas très loin d'ici mais
très vite j'ai compris que je n'aimais
pas être sur scène d'où un léger stress
mais j'adorerais travailler
j'adorais dans un studio j'adorais
répéter alors j'ai décidé de venir corée
aux log
j'ai appris à écrire la danse donc
depuis 1992 je note les création du
chorégraphe angelin prejlocaj directeur
du centre chorégraphique national
d'aix-en-provence
je l'aide à transmettre son art aux
générations futures
dans un premier temps j'écris l'autre
partie de mon travail c'est de faire des
reconstructions
quand un nouvel interprète doit
apprendre une chorégraphie
je dois lui transmettre le mouvement
donc lui donner toutes les informations
nécessaires et indispensables pour
danser le mouvement correctement peu
danseur apprennent cette écriture
alors comment ça marche
donc ça s'appelle la corée au logis ça a
été inventé par johan des neiges
danseuses et son mari rudolf musiciens
mathématicien et qui s'étonne de voir sa
femme écrire avec des mots la danse
qu'elle danse à londres et donc il
décide de fabriquer une écriture qu ils
vont appeler corée au logis ou notation
mais neige comment ça marche
c'est très simple penser à l'homme de
vitruve c'est le plan frontale ensuite
ils vont utiliser des signes et chaque
signe va donner l'idée de la 3d si
j'écris un signe devant moi si j'ai une
main devant moi je vais écrire un signe
verticale le petit bonhomme devancé
verticale au niveau du corps l'homme de
vitruve c'est un signe horizontal et 6
et derrière ça va être un point de ces
trois signes de vases ils vont
développer des croix ces trois veulent
dire un coude au niveau du corps d'un
homme de vitruve ou un genou une croix
verticale un coude ou un genou devant et
une croix du point de croix derrière je
vais écrire les coudes et les genoux que
s'ils sont pliés le système et
économique alors un mouvement c'est quoi
c'est aller d'un point a à un point b
donc on va écrire sur une partition
cette partition et représente le sun les
genoux chaque ligne
la taille des épaules la tête et nunes
imaginaire quand j'ai des bras au donc
si je veux capte des instants clés je
vais repéré un premier instant et un
deuxième instant et puis je vais écrire
ce qui s'est passé en symbolisant et en
écrivant sur ma partition les signes
donc je vais écrire deux pieds demain et
puis
la deuxième je vais monter les bras et
je vais écrire le mouvement quand j'ai
une partition avec plusieurs mouvements
je vais les écrire les uns après les
autres sur la porte et je vais toujours
écrire ce qui concerne mon corps à
savoir inclinaison rotation mouvements
des bras
et puis ligne de pain si je marche ligne
de songes glisse au sol etc
je prescrire plein de trucs sous la
partition je vais écrire l'espace mon
orientation générale
mon déplacement en avant en arrière sur
le côté et cetera mes relations avec les
partenaires ou autre au dessus de la
porte et je vais écrire le temps et les
qualifications
donc là on voit une ligne de legato sait
comment même mise en musique ça veut
dire que tous les mouvements qui sont
sous cette ligne ne font qu'un mais il
se hisse ils durent dans le temps je
peux écrire aussi au dessus de la
partition des qualifications donc ici
vous avez un petit triangle noir qui
veut dire un accent qui fait du bruit
puis un accent qui fait pas de bruit
donc les signes sont toujours logique
ils deviennent complexes quand je touche
le sol que je touche un objet et que
quelqu'un touche tout ça en même temps
mais la logique et la rigueur du système
font que je retrouve mes signe à chaque
fois et ça vous permet de les relire
facilement si j'ai plusieurs danseurs
qui ne font pas le même mouvement mais
tout se passe en même temps et bien
c'est comme en musique
je vais mettre plusieurs lignes donc là
j'ai quatre danseurs qu'apporter leur
mouvement et leur relation dessous la
première portait quand je suis une
création
je vais écrire tout ce que je peux je
vais faire un brouillon et ça change et
ça rechange essarts hors change et ça
n'aurait pas de changer une création
voilà donc c'est un brouillon mais
ensuite je vais relire je vais nettoyer
et je vais faire une partition plus
propre ceci est la partition du passage
des bibles
de suivront mille ans de calme
chorégraphie danger d'un précieux cage
la notation ou corée au logis permet
beaucoup de souplesse je peux écrire en
français
les indications les intentions du
mouvement et des didascalies qui
permettent de préciser comment je dois
interpréter le mouvement comment théâtre
j'écris tout ce que je veux je peux
rajouter des pages c'est pas figé c'est
un témoignage originelle des intentions
du chorégraphe tout ce que vous ne savez
pas en tant que public
mais vous percevez peut-être tout ce
qu'une vidéo n'expliquera jamais c'est
une des réponses à mes une vidéo n'était
pas plus efficace qu'une partition les
deux sont parfaitement complémentaires
et une vidéo déjà donne une idée
d'ensemble d'une chorégraphie et puis
une vidéo
si vous la prenez une chorégraphie en
copiant une vidéo vous allez copier une
interprétation au risque de ne pas
trouver la vôtre
la notation du mouvement transmet de
mouvement
rien que du mouvement penser au jeu du
bouche à oreille à la fin d'information
légèrement déformé la vidéo c'est un
point de vue c'est un cadrage l'écriture
de la danse c'est un langage un signe
n'a qu'un seul sens
il est plus simple de retrouver un petit
compte sur une partition que de chercher
sur une vidéo ou une orientation
la vidéo c'est bien mais on a tous dans
nos placards des vidéos cuite par la
chaleur la dotation père mais bon j'ai
écrit sur une pâle une tablette bientôt
bien sûr mais quand j'écris sur une
tablette
j'imprime toujours mes partitions le
papier reste le support qui résistent le
mieux au temps et aux évolutions
technologiques pour revenir à la vidéo
on les a dans nos placards elles sont
cuites par le temps où on n'a plus du
tout le matériel adéquat pour les lire
la chorale gîte un outil ça nourrit
riche très riche c'est puissant j'écris
un mouvement et je peux mettre des
beaucoup de précision direction des yeux
contact et mouvements des doigts forme
de la bouche les plus grands peintres
nous ont laissé des chefs-d'oeuvre garni
car la joconde
les nymphéas les cinq victoires on
admire les trésors des civilisations
éteinte comme les égyptiens ou les mayas
pourquoi ne pas laisser l'art immatériel
aux générations futures la mémoire
permet d'avancer dans tous les arts des
courants apparaissent en réponse au
passé ils s'opposent ils se nourrissent
il se dépassent écrire la danse c'est
perpétuer son histoire c'est inscrire
c'est courant dans tous les arts donc en
musique on remixe gainsbourg s'est
inspiré de chopin de brahms de beethoven
la chronologie ne se restreint pas à la
danse contemporaine classique
folklorique ou autre peu de chorégraphes
n'utilise mais dans les arts du cirque
en particulier ils écrivent leurs
numéros traditionnels ou de création en
voltige et en jonglage un jeune homme
est venu me voir il ya
peu de temps pour me montrer une
partition de jonglage je ne sais pas
anglais mais je saurai expliquer je
serai je sais ce qu'il faisait au tout
début de ma carrière on m'a appelé pour
écrire un défilé sur les champs elysées
avec dix mille personnes et il n'y avait
qu'une répétition il fallait tout
organisé tout expliquer
donc j'ai fait des partitions pas des
partitions de danse mais des partitions
il ya quelques temps j'ai reçu un mail
j'ai cru que c'était une blague
est ce que je pourrais avoir une
partition pour l'envoyer sur la lune en
fait je résume mais c'était çà et là je
lis et je vois nathalie besson
physicienne au commissariat à l'énergie
atomique et là j'ai fait une super
blague c'est pas du twin bague
donc ça s'appelle sans tuer project
c'est un projet pour célébrer le premier
pas de l'homme sur la lune et ils vont
envoyer des capsules dans lesquels il y
aura en particulier la recette du génome
humain
il y aura ce que l'on n'est ce que l'on
aime et ce que l'on fait elle considère
que la danse est importante pour notre
civilisation et elle m'a demandé un
petit résumé de l'explication du système
benech puis d'écrire une petite
chorégraphie pour la lune
donc voilà vous avez la primeur et puis
elle m'a demandé une page de la
chorégraphie d'angelin preljocaj gravité
que nous allons voir danser
cette fois ci
et voici là bas âge qui correspond à ce
qu'on vient de voir voilà donc cette
page va être sur la lune
il est important de transmettre aux
générations futures notre culture
immatérielle comme la danse elles en
feront ce qu'elles voudront
mais quelle richesse
[Applaudissements]